je suis pas trop tard je suis non
voyantes complètement fait si je vous
pose des questions cette page sous sa
moye sanaa hip hop j'ai l'impression
qu'on me coûtait pas puis comme je suis
en dormant fait que ce soit au titre du
bruit c'est ça en fait je devrais
compter un peu mon cheminement mon
histoire à moi en neuf ans en 1976
j'avais 9 ans éjectées les olympiques
les jeux olympiques ici à montréal est
mon idole c'était nadia comaneci la
petite romane de 14 ans qui a gagné
plusieurs médailles d'or en gymnastique
et g sabo faire longtemps que je vois
plus long mais je me souviens très bien
de son image là avec sa queue de cheval
son petit tout perdre son maillot blanc
les deux mains nazaire l'eau puis je me
disais moi aussi je vais aller aux
olympiques un jour puis je vais gagner
des médailles par quand j'étais
complètement nul en gymnastique
j'ai décidé de jouer au basket
le g2 la grande mais cinq cartes que je
fais 120 livres mouillés ça que j'ai
joué tout le temps du secondaire puis
rendu au cégep
quand je suis rentré dans j'aime les
filles ça faisait tout cesser ces deux
faits que j'ai continué à marcher sortie
par leurs portes comme si je m'étais
trompé parce que je savais que j'avais
aucune chance et quelques années plus
tard à 20 ans je me suis mis à avoir des
gros gros maux de tête et amal voir dans
mon oeil gauche puis un moment donné
j'ai été voir un ophtalmologiste et en
regardant mes yeux il m'a dit ok on
appelle une ambulance d'un tumeur au
cerveau fait qu'à 20 ans quand tu te
fais dire ça ton ton monde bascule
légèrement beaucoup fait rendu à
l'hôpital j'ai été deux mois les
comprenais pas pourquoi que mon humeur
qui était du côté droit
affecté mon à gauche pour faire une
histoire courte finalement deux mois
plus tard
ils se sont aperçus que c'était pour une
cité portuaire mais plutôt une
malformation artérioveineuse c'était
congénitale à ma naissance j'ai des
vernets des artères de troc se sont
formés et à la longue année après année
comme une bulle de 5 qui a aussi mis à
grossir puis qui prenait trop de place
et avec le liquide céphalorachidien
entre tous qui m'ont expliqué ça finit
par écraser ménard optique ou mes
cellules de vision quand tu rentres à
l'hôpital à 20 ans on te disait quand on
est d'humeur au cerveau je pense que tu
vas perdre la vie puis deux mois plus
tard j'avais juste perdu la vue fake
oui ça a été un gros choc oui j'ai
pleuré j'en voulais à la vie j'en
voulais peut être le monde d'être dans
devenu aveugle dans le front mais bon
c'est là un moment donné je me suis dit
ok j'avais 20 ans j'avais été au
carrefour laval j'habite à laval à
l'époque puis il ya un monsieur qui
m'avait pris les mains puis me disait
vous allez vivre très très très vieille
je sais pas si c'est vrai ou paul mais à
l'époque à vingt et un jeu mais j'étais
dans ma version dans ma chambre puis je
me dis oh ouais j'ai 20 ans je suis
vraiment au vif très très vieille ça va
être longue si je continue de pleurer
comme ça au fait que je de toute manière
je gère tides heures et on dit anas la
philo mais ma mère jane tête et c'est ça
j'ai été faire mon mari adaptation 1 1
après avoir perdu la vue en fait un an
après le 13 mai 87
j'avais mon premier chien que je connais
ses membres aillent j'avais umicore de
canne blanche et j'ai commencé à jouer
au goal bas grâce à un gars qui qui est
à l'institut aussi et qui m'a parlé de
cette hausse par la gt sportive avant
j'ai commencé à jouer au global la gaule
base c'est un sport qui a été conçu pour
nous mais personne aveugle depuis
ce qu'il fait c'est tout est fait pour
nous le ballon à des grelots à
l'intérieur pour savoir où on est
souterrain il ya des lignes de pêche
surélevée par terre l'arbitré siffle une
fois ça veut dire quelque chose deux
fois ça veut dire autre chose faite tout
est fait pour nous puis très vite
en fait dès le premier entraînement
l'entraîneur m'a dit toi tu nous signe
un contrat de better place qu'oublier
pas j'avais toutes les références
j'étais très sportif quand je voyais on
ne voyait plus ça a été facile pour moi
puis je voudrais que grâce au sport pour
moi le fait de devoir me rendre aux
entraînements
j'avais une raison de sortir de chez
nous avec mon chien guillaume puis de
prendre l'autobus puis prendre le métro
puis de de faire ce que j'avais à faire
puis comme la présentatrice le dis j'ai
commencé en 88 puis en 92
j'allais à mes premiers paralympiques et
à personne n'est revenu que la médaille
de bronze fait pour moi c'était ce sont
encore les plus beaux jeux paralympiques
même si j'en ai fait un nom depuis que
j'ai gagné là parce que ça c'était les
premiers puis c'est la première fois
dans tout ça ou presque
c'est toujours ce qui qui irait sandales
et suite à ça dès que je suis revenue de
barcelone l'heureux le neuro chirurgie
m'a appelé tout de suite pour me dire ok
tu peux te rentrer je mens je rentre
même pas une semaine après pour pouvoir
enlever ma malformations que j'avais
dans le cerveau afin de depuis avoir
cette bombe à retardement la dent dans
la taille aps fait que j'ai été très
chanceuse
après dix huit ans d'opérations j'avais
plus mal formation puis en plus j'ai eu
aucun effet secondaire je peux
développer d'épilepsie je pourrais fait
que j'ai continué
à vivre comme ça hein en fait je je je
vous parle de ce téléphone j'ai gagné
des médailles d'or des médailles de
bronze dans mon frère le goal balle mais
ça ça m'a permis surtout de prendre
confiance en moi puis de côtoyer
d'autres personnes avec un handicap
visuel partielle ou totale et ça m'a
permis de voir que ben contrairement ce
que je vais passer ma vie à se terminer
par la ji retourner aux études j'ai fini
mon dec au cégep je me suis fait offrir
mon premier emploi à l'association des
sports pour aveugles de montréal j'étais
coordonnatrice des activités puis en 81
quelques mois avant d'aller aux jeux
paralympiques de barcelone j'ai décidé
d'arrêter de travailler pour me
consacrer plus à mon entraînement parce
que mon rêve s'en venait réalité puis je
voulais mettre tout les toutes mes
chances de mon côté d'être prête
physiquement psychologiquement pour
aller à ces jeux là le finalement ça
bien s'avérer aussi parce que j'ai on y
revenait qu'il médaille de bronze et
souhaité à ça j'ai eu un autre emploi ça
a été assez émouvant pour moi parce que
l'emploi en fait c'était dans une
centrale téléphonique et en prenait les
commandes chez pro pour les restaurants
mikes fait qu'on était peut-être 200
l'art de pointe lors entre 5h et 7h à
répondre au téléphone puis merci d'avoir
appelé max 30 minutes et ce pour une
raison fait que je connais comme speed
et quand j'étais passé l'entrevue
j'avais emmené mon cv puis la dame me
disais à regarde mon cv d'un petit os
au point qu'au bal samedi a toujours
golbal 1
vous connaissez sa personne connaît le
global at oui j'ai été un événement
bénéfice et il y avait deux personnes
qui revenait de barcelone qui nous ont
raconté ce jeudi d'un clan 10,1 adige
tangage est engagée c'est comme je me
dis à demain pour garder mon cv il a ce
même parce que chez faict écouter fait
qu'un pour moi lesparre c'est ça faisait
mon deuxième emploi que j'avais grâce à
aux stars fait que j'aie rester là
jusqu'à tincques la centrale
téléphonique ferme puis je travaille
être capté à minuit puis le 21 décembre
1995 il neigeait les cols bleus de la
ville de montréal est en grève donc
s'accumulaient de la neige au sol et ça
assourdi laissons fait que j'ai traversé
la première partie de décarie puis la
deuxième partie ben là je me suis fait
frapper par j'ai traversé sa lumière
rouge
j'entendais rien à cause de la neige
justement et j'ai été quand même
chanceuse parce que finalement j'ai eu
que les pôles de briser j'ai eu la tête
du péroné
puis une grosse capsules et à l'épaule
fait que je suis d'accord imminent
béninois s'est jeté encore siffler
exposé pays
mais tout ça pour vous dire que parce
que j'étais un athlète un golbal j'ai
été à la clinique de physiothérapie 10
parties québec puis après quelques
traitements la fusion hamdi leur vote
ferment à celle était trop petit trop
pas nier le fait qu'on n'est plus
capable de rien faire avec toi puis j'ai
été me faire masser par le
massothérapeute là qui travaillaient
l'appui qui me dit tu aimerais pas
s'adonner massothérapeute et les
personnes aveugles touché blabla je dis
oui je dise m1 mais admire hive mais
j'étudie j'accumule mon argent puis un
jour je vais me payer mon corps puis
deux traitements plus tard faisant il
dit je suis professeur dans une école on
a donné une bourse à une autre élève
l'année dernière puis peut-être qu'on
pourrait tant donné on va voir le
directeur de l'école fait que je dois
way qui ça fait que dubai christine
boudrias elle était athlète en patinage
de vitesse
j'ai fait que je parle puis j'y vais
mais dimon dans ma tête je me dis
christine boudrias tout le monde la
connaît au canada tout le monde sait qu
a fait gagner son équipe à nagano puis
je me devais qui connaît nathalie
chartrain qui connaît les paralympiques
et qui connaît le goalball
à part mon coach on s'est fait que je me
rends là puis finalement après
l'entrevue
le directeur et du bambin c'est beau on
sort au mois de septembre puis je vous
raconte tout ça ça m'émeut accord parce
que j'y croyais tellement peur de la
voir
cette bourse là que je me suis mis à
pleurer je me dis waouh
en plus quand j'avais fait mes
recherches pour la massothérapie c'était
à cette école là que je voulais aller en
particulier parce que c'est ta peau delà
taponnat grappille qui nous montrait
c'était vraiment d'un nom mais ça
devrait y colle lakic montre l anatomie
la pathologie la physio la physiologie
le site et ses tapageuses de minutes
seulement glace tu as vraiment
des thérapeutiques sportif c'est ce que
je voulais faire fait que j'ai travaillé
fort parce que j'étais la seule non
voyants de balcorp y avait aucun livres
en braille ou sur cassette mais j'ai été
très chanceuse parce que les les
étudiants qui étaient avec moi nalcor je
l'emmenais des enregistreuse puis tout
simplement et il devait lire les livres
aussi qui les lisent à voix haute
puis moi je pouvais aller lire fait que
j'ai été très chanceuse encore une fois
parce que tout le monde mis la main à la
pâte pour que moi je puisse réussir puis
maintenant je travaille en massothérapie
également j'ai deux emplois et quelques
uns à plus tard ce domaine pro fleurs
qui en fait ce qui était mon
massothérapeute il dit nathalie du
chapeau système rsa vous venez
travailler avec moi à la clinique parce
qu'ils ont nés deux hommes puis on aura
besoin d'une femme que ce soit
massothérapeute ou c'est juste un mois
travailler avec toi fait que je dis
waouh fait depuis 98 dans le fond que je
travaille aussi à la clinique de
physiothérapie de sports québec comme
massoud rappeur fait que je me disais
bien faut pas le dire fort mais je me
dis wow j'ai été chanceuse de me faire
frapper le 21 décembre parce que
j'aurais po lu tout seul il faut
toujours trouver le côté positif des
choses c'est ça puis bien monsieur quand
tu commences avant d'avoir une clientèle
où tu peux en vivre ça peut être longue
de monter ta clientèle fait que et
j'étais sur le conseil d'administration
de l'association sportive des aveugles
du québec puis moment donné on trouvait
pas personne pour être l'agente de
développement l'association puis le
directeur de l'époque hesdinois médite
wide
je connais les sports tu connais les
personnes handicapées visuelles 10
serait la meilleure fait que finalement
j'ai décidé de démissionner de mon poste
de présidente puis de devenir l'agent
l'agente de développement et depuis ce
faire
ben là j'ai monté j'ai été
coordonnatrice après j'ai été je suis
maintenant directrice générale je vous
raconte d'un peu tout ça oui j'ai deux
emplois puis j'habite tout seul puis je
me promène et je me déplace avec mon
chien guide en parlant de schengen je
vais juste vous expliquer un petit peu
comment ça fonctionne le chien me guide
ce point gps est pas un chauffeur de
taxi jeudi port en mémoire tel endroit
puis ma mère c'est moi qui dois lui dire
qui doit savoir dans un jeu m'avait
quand même rendre et je lui dit on à
gauche on à droite quand on arrive à une
intersection
le chien ne voient pas la lumière
qu'elle soit verte rouge aux jambes il
la voit pas c'est moi qui écoute et
quand le trafic parallèle par le
dimanche et en avant et son travail à
lui c'est de me faire traverser la rue
en ligne droite jusqu'au prochain
jusqu'au prochain jeu belge au trottoir
de l'autre côté un fake ces politiciens
je le sais que tout le monde veut voir
désigné l'opic dans le film de walt
disney et m'a lâché un guide de regard
de la lumière et quand la lumière passe
au vert
elle traverse sa maîtresse qui est
aveugle
c'est pas vrai fait que quand vous non
mais c'est parce que les gens et des
fois j'attends sur le coin de rue la
lumière est verte mais je ne sais pas ça
fait 2 secondes ou 15 secondes quel
hiver j'attends le prochain cycle j'ai
pas envie d'être premier dans le milieu
de la rue puis la lumière est tombé
rouge puis la légende dit madame votre
chien va pas sa job et verte la lumière
fait que je baise parce que oui a fait
sa job j ai pas dit traverser
factuellement n'y comprennent rien mais
bon fake c'est ça fait 4 quand
j'habitais j'habitais sur le plateau
mont royal pendant dix ans que j'avais
j'avais mon jardin j'avais même ma cour
en arrière qui va du gazon puis
j'attendais mon gazon puis tout le monde
me féliciter parce que je tendais moi
même mon gazon tous avec 40 par 60 à peu
près puis josée béland c'est moi qui l'a
aménagé autour de mes fleurs j'ai mis
des barrières pour être sûr de ne pas
passer son meilleur avec ma tondeuse
pour moi ça c'est facile
puis pour moi c'est pas une question de
courage ce n'est pas une question d'être
bonne c'est une question juste de pau
est paresseuse puis a été organisée mais
quand je traverse pie-ix au coin ontario
mme rodrigues des fois j'ai effacé quand
je traverse puis rendu le bar je
remercie la vie c'est parce que des fois
le réchaud c'est ça c'est courageux à
mon avis de traverser alors deux points
des rues passantes comme ça les yeux
fermés la sauce ajax appelé les mots
puis j'accepte que quelqu'un me dise que
je suis courageuse mais pas parce que je
fais ma vaisselle que je pense ma
balayeuse que je repense mon âge
pour moi c'est sécuritaire c'est facile
c'est dans la maison
si je vais faire mon épicerie
ben tout ce que je fais si le site est
accessible de l'épicerie
je vais voir que ce qu'ils ont à
spéciale j'écris ça sur mon ordinateur
qui ont une synthèse vocale la synthèse
vocale j'ai dicté aux pôles j'écris et
elle me répète ce que je viens de
décrire j'imprime le tout j'emmène sort
puis rendu à l'épicerie c'est le souvent
celles en valeur qui vient m'aider à
trouver les trucs sur les tablettes et
tout ce que j'ai à faire finalement
c'est d'aller payer puis de retourner
chez moi avec mon petit causse fait que
la mon petit problème que j'ai
présentement ce que l'aller les
terminaux point de vente
la machine estime attac art là il y en a
qui
des changes leurs terminaux de point de
vente et y met des bons terminaux point
de vente plus de boutons mal à moi je
peux payer s'il ya peu de boutons là
c'est fait que pour ceux qui ont voyagé
les téléphones sont partout pareils que
ce soit en australie au brésil
montréal le 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 étoiles 0
carrés sont partout pareils mais sur les
terminaux point de vente c'est la même
chose avec dès que je trouve mon 5e 5
toujours une pinoche ou un petit lit
fait qu'à partir du 5 je peux composer
mon équipe et faire enter mais leur peau
de python je peux plus face au fait que
ces deux commerçants ici s'il vous plaît
quand vous allez changer vos prochains
terminaux pense à moi il n'y a pas juste
moi là mais c'est la même chose parce
que ça m'est arrivé d'être dans un taxi
en ne sachant pas que ces nouveaux
terminaux la existait la fin de la
course
il donne des machines mail à chaque fois
j'essayais de trouver mon cinq jeux ps2
habitants ont pu rentrer mais j'étais
obligé de donner mon peuple
puis je passerai que beaucoup de monde
qui accepteraient de décembre sont n'est
pas quelqu'un qui connaît paul je fais
confiance le meti faut pas se mettre
dans des situations qui pourraient être
mal tourné finalement fait que dans le
fond ce que j'essaye de vous dire c'est
que je peux je m'aime pas je peux je
mène une vie très normal j'ai deux
emplois je vais travailler je prends
l'autobus je prends le métro je vais
faire mes courses à la condition que
tout est assez adapté ou penser un petit
peu pour nous le site internet
et quand internet est arrivé à kaboul ou
enfin je vais avoir accès à
l'information que j'avais pas avant fait
que j'aurais aimé ça va j'aurais aimé ça
qu'internet soit plus a été inventé
avant que l'eia ce n'est parce que à
part savoir qu'ils avaient des
kangourous
parce que j'avais écouté skippy quand
j'étais jeune j'avais vraiment pas que
ce cas là ce n'est mai
après quand je suis revenue j'ai pu
aller lire de ce puits ça a été pour
nous là ça a été vraiment le fun pour sa
part contre le plus ça avance
des fois il ya des trucs
il ya beaucoup d'image c'est on dit
qu'une image vaut mille mots
ben moi j'aime mieux les mille mots mais
je vous jure je comprends avant mille
mots la tige s'est expliquée mois en
vain le jeu va comprendre j'en ai pas
besoin d'eux mais elle met en images sur
votre site internet samedi rien j'ai
fait que mettez des images mais mettez
des mots pour nous là qui voit pas ça ça
nous aide beaucoup à rester autonomes
parce que j'aime ça a été une citoyenne
qui qui qui participent à la vie à sa
vie communautaire qui aide les gens à se
relever de la table de massage qui peut
avoir un mal bordeaux puis enfin faire
des sports aux personnes handicapées
visuelles et qui peuvent prendre
confiance en eux de la stime deux
présidents ont séché bon en faisant le
sport ben je peux être bon à l'école
puis je fais capable de me trouver un
travail fait je veux rester autonome je
veux participer à la vie de mon quartier
à la vie de la ville de montréal à être
peut-être un exemple des fois pour
certaines personnes mais en même temps
j'ai besoin tout le monde sait que les
gens pensent à nous aussi dans ce qu'ils
font dans que ce soit un site internet
qui soit accessible que ce soit de
trouver d'avoir un terminal de point de
vente accessible que ce soit d'avoir une
voiture électrique fait du bruit
comme je vous ai dit tantôt nous on
traverse avec le son mais si votre auto
électrique fait pas de sens ça peut
faire bobo s'est fait que en principe il
devrait avoir une loi qui va passer par
rapport à ça mais penser
pensez-y baisser vos fêtes et la musique
forte quelque chose que je sache que
vous êtes là fait que c'est tous des
petites choses comme ça qui fait que on
peut rester autonome puis enfin partie
de la vie comme tout le monde c'est bon
[Applaudissements]